we're on problem where are we 154
an empty pool being filled with water at
a constant rate takes eight hours to
fill to three-fifths of its capacity so
you could say it takes you can fill
three fifths of a pool
every eight hours
which is just another way of saying that
you can fill let's see three-fifths
divided by eight is three
over
what's 5 times 8 3 over 40
pools per hour i'm a feeling that
they're just going to ask us something
along just the rate of the fill okay
so then they say how much more time will
it take to finish filling the pool
oh well this actually is is a little bit
easier so if you take it takes eight
hours
to go
to to fill the pool to three-fifths of
capacity
how many hours will it take to finish
filling the pool so how many hours will
it take to
fill it essentially what what's left
two-fifths
right to fill it two-fifths more
let's see let's multiply we can actually
so this is going to be the same thing as
eight
is to three is equal to x over two and
you could do that by dividing both sides
of this equation by five right then
you'd get a five in the denominator both
places which cancels out and now this is
easy eight is the three eight is to
three as x is to two so you have 16 is
equal to 3x
and then you get x is equal to
and 1 3 hours that's 5 hours and 20
minutes because a third of an hour is 20
minutes
and that is choice b
problem 155
a positive number x is multiplied by two
all right
fair enough x is multiplied by 2 and
this product is then divided by 3
okay and they told us x was positive if
the positive square root of the result
of these two operations equals x
so the positive square root of these
operations that is equal to x
what is the value of x and let's solve
this so square both sides of this so we
get
2x over 3 is equal to x squared
and then multiply both sides by 3 you
get 2
x is equal to 3
x squared and they tell us that x is
positive
right so we could divide well first of
all that tells us that x does not equal
0 they tell us that x is greater than 0.
so let's see let's divide both sides of
this equation by x
and well there's a couple of ways we
could think about it let's just
maybe the easiest way yeah let's just
divide both sides of this equation by x
and we can do that because we know that
x cannot equal 0 and you get 2 is equal
to 3x
and then divide both sides by 3 you get
x is equal to 2 3. and that's choice d i
was thinking about saying oh well let's
subtract 2x from both sides you get 3x
squared minus 2x is equal to 0. you
could factor out an x
and then you get 3x minus 2
times x is equal to 0 and that would
tell you that either 3x minus 2 is equal
to 0 which would get you that answer or
x is equal to 0 but x can't equal 0
because they told us that x is positive
but anyway it gets you the same answer 2
3.
next question
problem
156 a tank contains 10 000 gallons of a
solution
okay 10 000 gallons
of a solution that is
sodium chloride by volume 5
sodium
chloride
what is that nacl this is in chemistry
let's see if 2500 gallons of water
evaporate from the tank
so 2500 gallons of water evaporate the
remaining solution will be approximately
what percent sodium chloride so they're
essentially saying well if if water
evaporates the so the salt in the in the
solution doesn't go away right the the
salt doesn't evaporate with the water so
if we if we're five percent sodium
chloride what's five percent of ten
thousand
let's see five percent of ten thousand
five percent of a
five percent of 100 is five five percent
of a thousand is fifty five percent of
ten thousand is five hundred
so there's
you could say there's five hundred
i guess you could say there's 500
gallons of sodium chloride
right 500 gallons of sodium chloride if
we lose 2500 gallons of the water now
the percentage of sodium chloride is
still 500
but it's going to be 500 over what we
don't have 10 000 gallons of water
anymore we have 10 000 gallons of water
minus 2500 gallons of water
so we have 7 500 gallons of water
and let's see that's equal to 5 over 75
which is equal to
1 over 15 and what is that as a
percentage 15
as a percentage
see 15 goes into a hundred i know what
six times it's not seven yes six times
six times five is thirty
six times one is six plus ninety and
then i have a 10.
so she keeps going on
0.066 repeating so it's six and
two-thirds percentages or six point well
let's see they have choice yeah choice d
looks right 6.67 percentage if you round
this it just keeps repeating with six so
that is choice
d
problem 157
if x plus 5y
is equal to 16
and x
is equal to minus 3y then what does y
equal so let's just substitute
this over here so we get minus 3y
plus 5y
is equal to 16.
add those together you get 2y is equal
to 16 or y is equal to 8
and that is choice e
problem 158
a committee is composed of w women and m
men so w and m
if three women and two men are added to
the committee and if one person is
selected at random from the enlarged
committee then the probability that a
woman is selected can be represented as
okay so what
what the probability of a woman being
selected is essentially the the fraction
of the women of the population that are
women so how many women are there
there's going to be w
plus three women
and what's the total population
well there's w plus three women
and then there's
m plus two men plus m
plus two men so this is the probability
we select a woman and then we can just
simplify this a little bit that equals w
plus three
over w plus m plus five
and that is choice e
problem 159
if the product of the integers
w let me get rid of that up there the
product of the integers w
x
y
and
z
is 70. so let me just write that w x y z
is equal to 70 oh 770
and if
is less than w which is less than x
which is less than y which is less than
z
what is the value of
w
plus z
okay this is interesting so they're
telling us that these are integers
right and we have four integers
and they're all greater than one
so let's see let's see if we can do a
prime factorization of 770 because i
have a feeling that that is what it's
going to come down to if we just look at
the factors of 770. so let's see that's
equal to
7 times 11
is
right 7 times 11 times 10
right 7 times 11 times 10 is 770 right
and then 10 is so that's equal to 7
times 11 times see what's ten
ten we can rewrite it as two times five
so that's its prime factorization and lo
and behold we have exactly four numbers
and let's put them in order so that
equals two times five
times 7 times 11.
and so this is what w x y and z
have to be because they're different
numbers they're all greater than 1 and
they're all integers so let's see they
want to know what w plus z so w plus z
is 2 plus 11 is 13. and that's choice
b
choice b
oh it looks like we have time even for
another one
let's do this one
all right the figure above shows a
circular fla a circular flower bed let
me see if i can draw it
so that's the outside and then they drew
the inside
so
if i do it like
see what the inside
oh didn't do a good job
let me see if i can draw the inside
maybe if i put it there
uh
it's not showing up the way i want to
let me do it let me move it around a
little bit
well let me just
erase it and try to draw one more time
well i think you get the idea all right
and they tell us
they tell us that the distance from the
center
to here is eight feet
okay the circuit the figure above shows
a circular flower bed with its center at
o and surrounded by a circular path that
is five feet wide so this is five
that is three feet wide i'm having
trouble reading three feet wide what is
the area of the path in square feet
so it's essentially the area of this
outside circle minus the area of this
inside circle right that would be the
area of this path
so what's the area of the outside circle
well the area of the outside circle it
you go eight to get to the this edge and
then you have three more so its radius
is 8 plus 3 is 11. so the area of the
outside area of the outside is equal to
pi
times 11 squared and what's the area of
the inside
area the inside is equal to pi
times the inside radius times 64
squared so the area of our of our path
is going to be area of the outside minus
the area of the inside which is equal to
121 pi right that's 11 squared times pi
minus
oh sorry it's 8 squared which is 64
right i should have written 8 squared
there so that minus 64 pi
and that is equal to what's 121 minus
64. 121 minus 64
is let's see
we have 21 plus 36
21 plus 36 that's equal to 57
pi
and that is choice
d
see in the next video